our talk show Titans week continues with
the daddy of the DNA test in the case of
three-year-old Carlito
rashon you are not Titan are you kidding
called survivor there are 75 daytime
talk shows in the graveyard okay
and so you worry about that all the time
you just don't want to go to the
cemetery
Marco you are not more he found talk
show ratings gold by asking one
provocative question who's the daddy
they said we have this idea we want to
do paternity test and we can ever
resolve within 10 or 12 minutes and the
audience that's all they're looking for
as a result you build that up with the
drama I said I don't wanna know the
result if I know the answer I will skew
my questions I don't want to know
anything more than the people I'm
talking to and that was the key that key
unlock nearly 30 years of you are not
the father in the case of two-year-old
deasia Marquis you are not
James you are the father today
Maury works only two days a week and
makes an estimated 13 million a year
worth a reported 60 million more he
still gets 100 calls a week asking if he
can help determine paternity and he's
got this cool story about what happened
behind the scenes when he got together
with his fellow talk-show Titans Phil on
his 25th anniversary he invited all the
talk-show hosts to do a segment we were
all in agreement I'm telling you it's me
Oprah and we were all in the green room
waiting to go on all big time talk-show
hosts and we never said a word to each
other
there was silence the entire time we
were so into ourselves who the heck know
where do we need each other for more you
still married to Connie Chung and here's
one thing you may not have known about
the first show he hosted a Current
Affair you know the show that went we
wanted this sound that whenever somebody
heard that they would stop what they
were doing and watched the show and they
named it as a gift to my wife so they
called it the Connie pachow
[Music]